elle ne s'y attendait pas malgré sa
détermination cette médaille d'or et ce
titre national de plus jeune fleuriste
sont une surprise pour Maïwenn
on est fier de soi on est fier de ce
qu'on a accompli après tout n'est pas
accompli ça c'est évident mais pour
l'instant t on est quand même très
content de de ce qu'on a pu faire sur le
moment quoi et ça je pense qu'il y a pas
plus belle on va dire récompense élèves
à l'école internationale d'art floral de
Fondettes Maïwenn a déjà décroché son
CAP son brevet professionnel et HF sa
deuxième année de brevet de maîtrise
l'équivalent d'un Bac +2 ici on est
particulièrement fier d'elle c'est une
personne qui a beaucoup beaucoup de
talents et donc du coup on est très très
heureux pour elle par contre c'est c'est
sa réussite à elle effectivement elle
fait partie de l'école des fleuristes de
Fondettes mais pour autant c'est ça sa
réussite à elle
les cours se poursuivent malgré tout
longue gestion management au milieu des
lèvres japonaises irakienne ou
venezuelienne et là encore Maïwenn se
distingue la particularité c'est qu'elle
donne également des cours pour les CAP
brevet professionnel et elle suit ses
cours pour son brevet de maîtrise
fais attention de bien rester avec mon
adhésif floral de pas le faire trop
large par rapport à mon bouquet cette
tour en gel d'origine bretonne compose
ses ambitions comme un bouquet par étape
passionné par la voix qu'elle s'est
tracée plein de choses qui me plaisent
le métier de fleuriste la créativité
la fleur la proximité la clientèle
les élèves du coup aussi
avec ce titre la jeune femme est d'ores
et déjà qualifiée pour la Coupe de
France 2024 avant de viser le concours
de MOF meilleur ouvrier de France dans
sa discipline